welcome thanks
we have so much to talk about let's get
to it
let's do this thing all right uh but
first i have to mention something you
know last time you were on the show
we were talking and you mentioned a
character that uh that you used to do
it was one of my favorite things and uh
that i'd seen on the show in a while and
if it's okay i'd like to ask you to do
it again it's you do a character called
the german who says
nice things and i really loved it okay
do you mind if i just did dip back in
that pool for just a second no sure i'll
do a couple of them
this is yeah the german yeah yes
the german who says nice things all
right is this my camera
yes
it was a pleasure babysitting kevin
you are not getting older you are
getting better
i would like another dish a spaghettios
what a pleasant fellow
see it goes against common um
assumptions about germany yes terrible
common assumptions yeah and
that's why it is inherently humorous ah
very good thanks because i was confused
i didn't know why i was laughing would
you like
to uh to throw me a couple and i will i
will try to uh
uh let's see uh i just went to the
caribbean and the sky was a beautiful
teal blue
all right
i just went to the colombians
and this guy what a beautiful
i like writing for that character he's
fun
i will lose my voice after a while
uh now what about any are any new
characters uh kicking around in that
mind of yours i've worked up
i've been working on one um this is
called the joyless
laughing guy joyless laughing guy yeah
i'll try to do it
i can do it sitting down okay
i don't think they can say it's very
nice i don't think there's a vein
oh they're talking about there's a
series of veins on the side of your
forehead that in hd we're really popping
out
people at home
blood shooting uh you know i have to say
um
sometimes when uh when a movie's about
to come out you see the poster here and
there
i would say for the last three weeks uh
i can't go
anywhere without seeing the poster for
the 40 year old version of virgin and i
have to say
it is probably my favorite movie poster
of all time i think it's a hilarious
it's pretty scary it's well it's really
funny we have the picture this this is
her
that is i can't remember every time i
see that poster i start laughing and i
can't remember
any movie poster making me laugh
consistently i would like to see you
uh do the poster i'd like to see you i
think you can replicate that
i think you think i can do that all
right let's see if you help me all right
okay
put it up there okay uh i can be this
guy
so you look look up
okay a little more a little more eyebrow
now
can i do a little something of my own
like that or is that not helping oh i
like that
yeah thank you i don't know how that
makes me feel
right are you attracted to me now and uh
slightly
the poster is everywhere in manhattan
it's all over
there are posters facing posters facing
other posters you can be boxed in by
these posters i was in a convenience
store can we say convenience store on
the show
uh no not really uh
a 24 hour store 24-hour career
yeah um i was in a convenience store and
a kid came up to me and said hey
you're the virgin so i think i'm
actually literally going to be a poster
boy for virginity
yeah that's bush uh president bush has
contacted me absolutely
being the representative the uh the
president's council on virginity
abstinence that'd be and i'm gonna have
a bomber jacket
with the presidential seal and i'm gonna
go around to schools and give
speeches and that's if the movie doesn't
do well yeah
you're just gonna blanket the area it
does do well i'll i won't ever do that
joking
yeah yeah yeah you won't have to exactly
now um
who's seen the movies your wife seen the
movie she didn't see it until the
premiere
and how did that go it must be weird to
work on something for so long and then
have your wife there
it was interesting um because it's the
first time i've ever made out
with anyone uh in front of my wife
that you know about yeah and um so
it cause in the movie you uh yeah i mean
i i
well i co-wrote it yeah and i have a lot
of make-out scenes so that
just implicit in that is a little
weirdness yeah with my wife
right um so we're sitting at the
premiere and there's a scene where
catherine keener and i are starting to
make out i'm on top of her and
i just felt my wife's her whole body
just
tensed up and and the problem was she
knows i'm not that good an actor
and she can see it in my eyes she sees
the pure joy
and she's sitting here yeah yeah
watching and listening too
so it's a little odd why are you doing
that
no actually when when you when you do a
love scene
you have to go back and you have to loop
the lines
yeah so you have to loop you're kissing
as well as well as the lines because a
lot of times kisses don't make sound
sure so you have to actually stand in a
booth and go
wow
which begs the question why couldn't
anybody do that why do they have to get
steve carrell to come back and do that
they could get anybody to go
out loud it has a certain flair yeah i
guess i guess it's the way you do it
yeah it's so cool
uh now you had your chest waxed
uh in the movie and you really went for
it they didn't do it in a fake way they
didn't use prosthetics you really had
your chest waxed i did
um i felt that that would if nothing
else would make the crew laugh
and uh and you and if you look at the
take
we had to do it in one take because my
hair grows fast but not that fast
right they were pulling it off and you
can see blood
beating to the surface oh my god yeah
yeah yeah it was
so unadvisable stupid
um about five seconds before they
started doing it i thought
this was a terribly terribly uh stupid
thing to do
right you also and i i mean you you uh
you're a you're a hairy guy
i don't know how else to say it you took
off your shirt and there's just you know
what do you mean i mean
as a compliment because i am smooth like
a child but
you uh i am harry i'm very i am very i'm
like an aerodynamic i'm a guy on a luge
team
you you it's just uh it's crazy a bad
loser
yes i would be um yeah i'm i'm if you
look at that
that chart of uh of uh
like going from ape to man yeah i'm
about four down from man i'm like
i'm not hunched over when you're the guy
with stone tools
yeah stone tools yeah i'm this
um when you can see your body hair
in your own shadows
oh yeah it's coming back though
coming back fast women dig it so hard
no that was weird
you